hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round two of this
year's video World Cup it is the second
game of the match Magnus Carson vs 11
pencilia we've seen what happened in the
first one Magnus won a very nice game
and here it's a very short game okay it
could be considered even a miniature in
modern times as anything about the 30
moves is considered a miniature
especially with a finish such as this
one uh I'm sure you guys will enjoy it
let's check it out uh it's it's quite
the game so Magnus has the Mind pieces
and he opens with C4 uh Pawn to C5 going
for the symmetrical variation of the
English sorry about that we have Knight
to F3 by Magnus and now G6 we have Pawn
to D4 and Bishop to G7 Pawn to D5 and D6
so 11 basically playing a benoni without
Knight to F6 now what's the idea of this
well obviously to take Magnus off guard
the E4 we have E6 H3 by Magnus and now
Knight to E7 so a very very odd setup
and not a lot of games featuring uh this
exact setup in the database Knight to C3
with H6 and now uh there is a game where
Bishop to D3 was played uh Boris
girlfriend played against um vessel into
Apollo in the 20 uh 2004 uh amber Rapids
tournament and uh a girlfriend won a
very nice game with Bishop to D3 Bishop
to D3 is also the engine top move uh but
here Magnus goes for D captures and E6
instead and it is now already as of move
eight that we have a completely new game
now look at the idea Bishop captures an
E6 and now Bishop to F4 going after the
D6 pawn and 11 sacrifices it he's really
going all out against Magnus in a game
two he wants to strike back with Queen
to A5 but not right away first he played
Knight B to C6 and only after Queen
captures on D6 he goes Queen to A5 now
the thread is Bishop captures on C3 and
then he will play Queen captures and
then hopefully win The Rook on A1 so
Magnus just brings the queen back Queen
to D2 and now Knight to B for preparing
Rook to d8 which will attack the Queen
and then the Knight will get a very nice
outpost on D3 so okay Magnus calculates
this out we have Pawn to A3 uh Pawn to
G5 first attacking the bishop and the
bishop the H2
uh we have rooked the d8 now attacking
magnus's Queen here and you cannot go to
C2 to keep an eye on the D3 Square so
Magnus plays Queen all the way to C1 and
now the Knight to D3 uh which means that
now Magnus has the part with his Bishop
fair but I'm sure he was also very happy
to do this as it will allow him to
Castle to safety so Bishop captures D3
Rook captures on D3 and now finally uh
uh Magnus castles to safety uh Bishop
captures on C4 and now Knight to D5 and
this is now a very very tricky move by
Magnus because the Knight on E7 is
hanging and also the bishop on C4 is
hanging so how do you uh how do you play
this well you just have to capture on D5
and take the extra Pawn so first 11
sacrifice the pawn for the attack uh
Magnus Defender and now Magnus is
sacrificing a pawn for his attack and
hopefully for him 11 will not be able to
defend it so Bishop captures on the 5e
characters Rook captures now Magnus is
the one who's down a pawn and we have
Rook to one not allowing the king to
Castle as the Knight on E7 will be
hanging so Queen to d8 defending the
Knight and now Queen to C4 uh the the
idea is uh not a very tricky one if uh
for some reason 11 castles uh then just
Rook character Sun E7 wins material
Queen captures Queen captures Rook on D5
uh and you're uh Europe a full piece uh
so after a queen to C4 King the f8 by 11
uh now just sidestepping with the King
and now also the Knight can move and now
uh look at this beautiful Knight the E5
move uh so how do you how do you counter
this Knight to C6 and now Rook 8 to D1
and here we have Knight the D4 the trick
of course is if uh uh Rook capture Sun
D1 is played Magnus just delivers
Checkmate on F7 a queen captures on F7
so after this Rook the D1 move we have
Knight The Thief
uh sorry about that and after Knight the
D4 just Kink the H1
uh we have Pawn to be five chasing away
the White Queen from the C4 Square Queen
to D3 and now Pawn to H5 11 just
pretending his King isn't weirdly placed
on f8 uh but Magnus will have none of
this look at this uh beautiful uh
horsing around move uh Knight sorry
Knight to C6 attacks the queen uh and
the Knight on D4 but also you cannot
capture the Knight with the Knight
because then Queen captures on D5 so
Queen to be six by eleven and now
Knights to E7 nicely connecting with the
Rook we have Rook back to d8 and now
Knight to F5 again attacking the bishop
and the Knight here and what you should
play here is just move the bishop Bishop
to F6 and you you play it cool you know
it's Bishop T5 you play Rook Rook to
Jade you can play Rook to G6 next
uh and so on however after this Knight
the F5 move 11 played a queen to G6 this
nicely aligns with the queen on D3 uh
but also he blunders the game completely
but it's not easy to spot why now Magnus
took his time here when he found it he
he really smiled uh uh uh with a really
big smile so try to do this you could
also smile while you're solving it feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen has been plundered and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to C7 this is the move
that wins the game as The Rook uh The
Rook cannot be saved the problem is uh
you cannot move the Rook if you move the
Rook let's say Rook to C8 then you no
longer control the D file and then just
Bishop to D6 check the king cannot go to
the E file you have to move and now
Knight the E7 check with a beautiful
Monster Royal Fork here uh of course you
will capture the queen but that's pretty
much it ah black loses too much material
so in the game rooked D7 was played by
11 and now comes the finisher that you
had to see when Bishop to C7 was played
and that is Rook to E8 with check this
is what the Magnus played and he was in
this position on move 29 that 11
panzalaya resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here truly a
spectacular finish by Magnus uh point is
that of course The Rook has to be
captured and after a rook is captured
you okay you can't capture the queen but
you can just deliver Checkmate Queen to
e for check and that's all there is if
you move the king king to f8 then a nice
Queen to A8 with check only move Rook to
d8 and queen captures will be Checkmate
and if you don't do that if after Queen
T4 check you try something like Knight
to E6 which is also possible still Queen
to A8 with check and after Knight to d8
you can just capture with the queen you
don't really care Queen captures real
characters and now a wonderful Rook
capture 78 Checkmate as the Knight
covers the E7 Square so also one of the
uh upsides of having a knight on F5 in
this line but yeah it didn't it didn't
come to all of this after magnets play
this beautiful Rook d8 move 11 resigned
which means Magnus takes both the game
one and game two uh he conquers round
two and he will now proceed to round
three of this this year's video World
Cup we haven't discussed what happens in
the end as the top three contenders are
qualified into the video candidates
tournament I imagine Magnus will play if
he qualifies but even if he qualifies
for the candidates and wins the
candidates of course he already said
that he will not be fighting for the
title of world champion under uh the
current rules maybe if the there will be
a change to the time format he would
prefer more rapid games uh a faster
classical and maybe slower rapid rather
than the two and a half hour games with
infinite infinite uh uh you know uh
checkpoints where you get more time now
you'll get more time after 40 moves and
then after 60 moves and then you know
you get even increment so it just takes
forever uh so yeah something that he
doesn't like but yeah we'll see if it
comes to that uh or he might not even
play the candidates tournament I'm not
sure he ever discussed this who knows
we'll we'll have to wait and see if he
if he actually gets to the to the
semi-finals or the finals uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
to very nicely played against the
Canadian Grandmaster 11 points Reliance
again he played well like in the
previous one but he gave Magnus one
opportunity Magnus took it and I mean
what a way that finish the game I just
this found this beautiful Bishop C7
followed by Rook T8 check and that's it
game over uh so I once again really do
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Seth Harper shoulder uh Paul
Harris Aaron is the best wife and
Richard Schwartz for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day